الان هذه الشكوى الجنائيه نجوان ضد الرئيس
الاسرائيلي الذي يشارك في دافوس ما هي
اصداء هذه المعلومات هذه
الشكوى في
اسرائيل
نعم هذا بطبيعه الحال ربما سيشكل تحول
كبير هنا في اسرائيل والبدء بالتفكير في
المرحله القادمه لمحاكمات قد تطال سواء
كان مسؤولين سياسيين في ال الجانب
الاسرائيلي وكذلك مسؤولين عسكريين دعيني
فقط ابدا من هذا الرد الذي نقلته قبل قليل
قناه القناه الثانيه ع في التلفزه
الاسرائيليه من ديوان الرئيس اسرائيلي
هيرتسوغ في رد على هذه الشكوى في سويسرا
اي يقول بان تقول هذه ال يقول هذا البيان
عفوا الرئيس الاسرائيلي انهى زيارته
للمنتدى الاقتصادي الدولي كما تم التخطيط
لهذه الزياره وهناك عرض موقف اسرائيل
وصدقها و عداله هذه الحرب والمعركه ضد
حماس ومن اجل ايضا المعركه لاستعاده
المختطفين هذا بيان مقتضب يبدو بان ديوان
رئيس الرئيس الاسرائيلي يتخك هيرتسوغ حوله
لقناه التلفزه الاسرائيليه الثانيه ع للتو
حتى الان لم تصدر ردود فعل اخرى على ذلك
الان فقط بدا يتم التعامل على مستوى
الاعلام الاسرائيلي مع هذا الخبر لكن
دعينا نشير الى عده نقاط في هذا السياق
ليله هناك دائما مخاوف لدى الجهات
الاسرائيليه من مثل هذه المحاكمات الدوليه
وهذا حدث في السابق في حروب سابقه تم منع
في احدى المرات وزيره الخارجيه
الاسرائيليه في حينه تسيي ليفني من هبوط
طيارت في واحده من الدول وول الاوروبيه
بسبب شكاوى جنائيه قدمت ض ضدها كمسؤول عن
واحده من الحروب كما اذكر كانت حرب 2014
في غزه وهذا تكرر مع عدد من المسؤولين
العسكريين لذلك على سبيل المثال عدد او
بالعاده هناك قانون في الجيش الاسرائيلي
جزء كبير من القاضى الميدانيين وتحديدا
الطيارين الذين يشاركون في الهجمات من
الجو لا يتم الكشف عن وجوههم او عن
اسمائهم على الاطلاق دائما هناك تعتيم
وتغطيه على وجوه تحديدا الطيارين العاملين
في سلاح الجو لانهم في هم من يقومون طيله
الوقت بتنفيذ الغارات القويه والمدمره في
هذه الح الحروب وشهدنا ذلك في هذه الحرب
نذكر ايضا ان الرئيس الاسرائيلي يحاك
هيرتسوغ رغم ان منصبه هو بروتوكولي اكثر
في اسرائيل
اي يعني لا توجد لديه صلاحيات مثل رئيس
الحكومه لديه منصب في اسرائيل اقل تاثيرا
هو اكثر في اطار البروتوكولي ولكن مع ذلك
توجه في هذه الحرب الى الحدود مع غزه وعبر
بطبيعه الحال عن دعمه للقوات هناك لكنه
قام بالتوقيع على واحده من القذائف
الصاروخيه وهذه الظاهره رايناها في هذه
الحرب على مستوى مؤثرين في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ممثل ين مغنيين عده اشخاص
قاموا بذلك ونشروا هذه الصور حيث قاموا
بالتوقيع على قذائف صاروخيه سيتم اطلاقها
على غزه وكانت بطبيعه الحال تحمل رسائل ضد
الفلسطينيين في غزه وهو ما قام به الرئيس
الاسرائيلي هيرتسوغ
وهو يعني كانت ربما خطوه انتقدت من قبل
الكثير حتى في المجتمع الاسرائيلي تحديدا
من قبل ممن يعرفون انفسهم باليسار
الاسرائيلي بان مثل هذه الخطوه غير ملائمه
لمنصب الرئيس الاسرائيلي لانه شخصيه لا
يمكن اعتبارها شخصيه سياسيه او شخصيه
عسكريه وانما هي اكثر شخصيه اعتباريه
ولديه منصب بروتوكولي اكثر لكنه مع ذلك
قام بهذه الخطوه وانتشرت صوره على مستوى
واسع في ال خلال هذه الحرب وهذا ليس فقط
بانه يؤيد هذه الحرب وانما ايضا يقوم
بالتوقيع على هذه القذائف التي تطلق
باتجاه المدنيين ايضا في غزه وبطبيعه
الحال اي يعني لها رساله واضحه عن دم عن
دعمه المطلق لهذه الحرب وان كانت تمس
الابرياء من جهه اخرى ايه في في الايام
الاخيره الماضيه بدات قضيه النقاش حول ما
كان يحدث قبل بدايه هذه الحرب من احتجاجات
واسعه في اسرائيل ضد التغييرات القضائيه
واليوم هذا النقاش يعود لماذا لانه واحده
من القضايا التي ايه خرجت من اجلها هذه
الاحتجاجات في اسرائيل قبل الحرب وامتدت
لتسعه اشهر مع بدايه هذه الحكومه الحاليه
بمحاوله اجراء هذه التغييرات كانت انه لو
تم تقويض واضعاف المحكمه الاسرائيليه
العليا في اسرائيل هذا سيمنح محاكم اخرى
دوليه في محاكمه مسؤولين عسكريين ومسؤولين
سياسيين في اسرائيل بمعنى لو ان المحكمه
العليا لا تقوم ولو شكليا في اسرائيل
باجراء تحقيقات او محاكمات تتعلق بما يوصف
بجرائم حرب فهذا سيفتح المجال امام
محاكمات دوليه اخرى ولذلك كان تحديدا لو
تذكرين قضيه الطيارين في اسرائيل الذين
اعلنوا في حينه الطيارين الحربيين اعلنوا
في حينه عدم الامتثال للخدمه من قوات
الاحتياط احتجاجا على هذه التغييرات لان
ذلك من وجهه نظرهم كان سيعرضهم للخطر اذا
ما سافروا الى دول اخرى قد ترفع قضايا
عليهم والان مع محكمه الجنايات العدل
الدوليه التي ايضا رفعت نعم